wenn es um spektakuläre kunst dreht
kommt man an ihm nicht vorbei am
dänischen künstler olafur eliasson
er ist ganz oben angelangt und ist in
den letzten 20 jahren zu einem der
gefragtesten künstler weltweit geworden
und zwar mit licht
in seiner neuesten ausstellung
verwandelt er den neu eingeweihten
kunsttempel des luxus riesen louis
vuitton in paris mit seinen
lichtinstallation
eliasson erschafft mit licht räume die
andere mit farbe ihre bilder
licht ist so beeindruckend weil es
gleichzeitig da ist und nicht da ist man
kann es nur sehen wenn es auf etwas
fällt und obwohl ich so schwer zu
verstehen ist hat jeder eine meinung
dazu
jeder kann was du dich sagen es ist sehr
demokratisch elias aufstieg zum weltruhm
verdankt er einer künstlichen sonne die
vor über zehn jahren zwei millionen
besucher in ihren bann zog
installiert in der turbinenhalle der
tate modern in london wurde das weather
project zu einem der größten
ausstellungserfolge eines künstlers
überhaupt
es folgten gigantische projekte in new
york inszenierte er auf dem hudson river
fünf künstliche wasserfälle und auf dem
dach eines technischen museums baute er
einen panorama rundgang der die farben
eines regenbogens nachempfinden soll
eliasson übertrumpft sich selbst mit
technisch raffinierten großprojekten
kopenhagen ein haus in einem ruhigen
wohnviertel
wir treffen eliasson in seinem atelier
wo er arbeitet wenn er nicht gerade die
welt bereist in der kunst hat er mit
licht alles erreicht doch er will mehr
eines abends saß ich mit meinem freund
einem ingenieur beim bier als wir
plötzlich merken dass dem dunkeln saßen
er hatte all diese kabellos solarpanels
mitgebracht und schaltete ein kleines
licht an ein wirklich witziges licht das
den ganzen raum erhält
es war beeindruckend und er sagte weißt
du was ich habe dieses licht vor ein
paar stunden bei mir zu hause aufgeladen
ich sagte das ist also das licht mit
denen du lebst
natürlich ist es dasselbe mainz
faszinierend war dass man das
sonnenlicht sozusagen samples kann wie
man musik sein bild und mitnehmen kann
wohin man will es war der anfang einer
idee die zu einer solarleuchte führte
die licht dorthin bringen soll wo es
keinen strom gibt in die entlegensten
dörfer afrikas dort wo bei dunkelheit
licht bildung bedeutet und die
produktivität erhöht solarlampen die bei
tag aufgeladen und bei nacht genutzt
werden können
petroleumlampen petroleum in der house
wenn ein fünfjähriges kind aufwächst mit
dem vertrauen in dieses kleine so leid
wenn dieses gleiche kind erwachsen ist
und vor der wahl stets in einer wohnung
oder einem haus eine energieform zu
wählen dann basiert diese entscheidung
auf emotionalen vertrauen war traurig
auf solarenergie oder auf öl
darum glaube ich ist es auch langfristig
wichtig vertrauen zu bilden in die
tatsache dass niemandem die sonne gehört
die sonne eine energiequelle ist und wir
sie nutzen können wenn wir wollen doch
wie finanziert man als künstler ein
solarprojekt in afrika elias von setzt
ein teil seiner lampen dort ab wo es
licht im überfluss gibt und ihn alle
kennen
im museum mit nächtlichen
museumsbesuchen schafft er ein
bewusstsein für das energieproblem in
afrika mit dem profit aus dem westen
reduziert eliasson den preis für seine
leuchte in afrika in licht muss billig
sein und doch soll der lokale verkäufer
daran verdienen damit eine nachhaltige
mikroökonomie entsteht
den ansatz den wir mit little star
verfolgen gab es vorher nicht
und das ist nicht nur wegen uns zu
sondern auch weil der preis für
solarpanels gesunken ist so dass er mit
der ölindustrie konkurrenzieren kann
der erfolgreiche künstler der in der
glamourwelt der grund zu hause ist trägt
jetzt sein soziales business zur schau
zwei welten die auf den ersten blick
nicht richtig zusammenpassen wollen
braucht es einen künstler um afrika zu
erhellen ist die kleine sonne nicht ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein
einige leute denken es gibt schon genug
solar leute und solarprojekte da draußen
aber das stimmt nicht
meine sicht auf die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist dass sie
ihre verantwortung falsch gemanagt hat
sie war bevormundend und unproduktiv so
dass die leute abgestellt wurden sie hat
eine sehr unheimliche sicht erschaffen
zwischen denen und uns
sie hat die welt polarisiert in und in
afrika und hier oben in europa das ist
auch eine generelle wissenschaftliche
diskussion und allmählich verändert sich
das mit licht will eliasson nicht nur
zum denken anregen er will die welt
verändern
doch er hat auch eine affinität zur
dunkelheit
er liebt nachteule tiere die auch ohne
licht nochmals sehen können